[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEANA JORGENSEN: Welcome to
Community Day at Next '21.
My name is Jeana Jorgensen.
And I'm here with Urs Holzle.
Today is unique in that
it will span an entire 24
hours to bring
together communities
from all around the world
in local time zones.
But before we get
into those details,
we wanted to share some
really exciting news with you.
URS HOLZLE: That's right.
But first, I'd like to thank
you all for your incredible
collaboration and
commitment to Google Cloud,
because developers are
really the core inspiration
behind everything that we build.
Your constant pursuit of
excellence motivates us.
And your feedback
pushes us to be better.
In a developer
keynote yesterday,
I announced the Google
Cloud Innovators Program.
With this program, we want
to bring all of Google Cloud
developers together
to co-create, to learn
from each other, and to
unite our global technical
communities where we're
supporting Google Cloud.
And we also want it to
reignite the human connection
that many of you have missed
over the last 18 months.
And that can be dismissed or
overlooked in online forums.
And finally, we know that
technical communities
can sometimes be
intimidating to new members.
And so our program's
primary design principle
is grounded in
inclusion and in serving
the community, regardless
of your knowledge base
or your status earned.
So I want to personally
invite each of you
to join us to become a
Google Cloud innovator.
So come share your experience,
coach and grow others.
Most importantly,
learn from each other
to build things that
have a meaningful impact
on the people who use them.
JEANA JORGENSEN: Terrific.
To join us, just sign up at
cloud.google.com/innovators.
We're really excited
to get to know you.
We also wanted to let you know
about a dedicated technical
community event we will
host for the first time
this coming February.
Twice a year in different
regions around the world,
we'll bring the users and
creators of Google Cloud
together to brainstorm,
learn, and get hands
on to move projects forward.
Google Cloud innovators will
be eligible for invitations
and speaking
opportunities early.
So please sign up to
be an innovator today,
and we'll share more details
about the event in the coming
weeks.
Urs, we've got a few more
pieces of good news to share.
URS HOLZLE: All right.
Yes.
We continue to invest
heavily, of course,
in developer experiences through
intuitive in-product usability
or through community engagement
to offer deeper recognition
of your expertise or through
access to tools and resources
that help you get your job done.
And another key investment is
in our learning experiences.
So, for example,
to meet the demands
of cybersecurity
professionals, Google
has pledged to train
100,000 Americans in fields
like data privacy, data
analytics, security,
and IT support.
And additionally,
"Tech News World"
cited that over
90% of IT leaders
expect to expand Cloud
Services over the next one
to three years, but over
80% identified a lack
of internal skills and
knowledge as a top barrier
to Cloud success.
And according to another study
done by Global Knowledge,
Google Cloud skills are
in super high demand,
commanding the top two paying
it certifications in 2021
in the US.
So I'm very happy to announce
Google Cloud Skills Boost.
Google Cloud Skills Boost is
the definitive destination
for Google Cloud learning,
including 700 labs, courses,
learning paths, skills badges,
and certification resources all
authored by Google Cloud.
The platform is
available globally today
in English, Japanese,
and Spanish,
with more languages
to follow soon
to enable millions of
people to build and validate
the skills that they need
to thrive in an evolving
Cloud-first world.
And finally, to
reaffirm our commitment
to accessibility of
these learning resources,
we are offering access at no
cost for 30 days to Google
Cloud Skills Boost.
So visit the website to
access free training today.
JEANA JORGENSEN: Fantastic.
OK.
Before we get on to the details
of how Community Day will run,
I have got two
questions for you.
OK, first question,
Google Cloud has
been talking about empathetic
engineering for quite some time
now.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about what that means
and why you think it strengthens
developer experiences?
URS HOLZLE: Sure.
By empathetic
engineering, we really
mean, how are we
putting ourselves
in the shoes of our
users, the developers,
and ensure that we build
products and services that
really start with
your needs first?
We've always been an
engineering-led company.
So what we needed
to learn was really
how you wanted to use our
services because users come
with different challenges
and different backgrounds
from different
industries, some of them
new to Cloud technologies.
So that's where customer
empathy comes in.
As an engineer, do you really
understand the experience
that real users have
with your products?
Are you really walking
in their shoes?
So we implemented a
listening and learning system
based on customer empathy.
So for example,
teams test products
by performing common user
journeys just the same way
customers would without internal
help, without internal tools,
without insider tips.
We gather the feedback.
We improve the services
or the documentation
and then test it
with real customers.
So we keep iterating until
we're confident that we've
built intuitive
services that are
easy for developers
to implement and build
great solutions around.
JEANA JORGENSEN: Great.
Thank you for that.
So here's my second
question for you.
If you were starting your
career in technology today,
where would you
focus your learning?
URS HOLZLE: Wow,
that's a huge question.
Because technology
evolves so quickly
that it can be
pretty overwhelming,
especially if you're
early in your career,
and unfortunately because of
the digital transformation
of many industries, the
success of those organizations
will increasingly depend on
the services and products that
are built by its developers,
so learning really
is super important.
Based on what I've
seen, I would probably
start with these three things.
First, you have to dedicate time
for learning every single week,
right?
So I'd start out by determining
what forms of learning work
for you independently
of the subject and then
really allocate a set of hours
to grow your knowledge base.
So for some, reading works best.
For some, it's videos.
For some, it's
interactive events.
You just got to understand
what works out for you.
And so next, I would pick
a couple of topic areas
that really interest
you and start
learning the fundamentals.
Joining online
communities or forums
can be a really good way to
get different perspectives
on the subject that maybe aren't
in the standard traditional
learning paths.
And then finally, of
course, the question
is, well, what subjects
should you go after?
Now, there's hundreds of them.
And so that's really
something that depends on you
and your preferences
and your situation.
But I'd say three
areas kind of come
to mind for me, first
customer empathy.
I already talked about it.
It's not something
that's taught in schools,
but it's really,
really important
that we build technology that
people actually want to use,
right?
And so when design
a product, and you
start with a deep understanding
what the customer actually
needs, then you can really
build more than just a solution.
You can create a viable
business and a viable product
that really lasts.
Second, learning what it
takes to ship a product,
also not broadly
taught in schools,
it's really invaluable in
almost every job that I've seen.
So that includes things like
the fundamentals of release
processes, lean or
agile development,
and how you best design products
for self-service delivery
because you want to
design your product such
that users can start
using it quickly
rather than depend on some
complicated instructions
or deployment process.
And then last but
not least, security.
You've all heard about
the growing cyber threats
that so many
organizations are facing.
And they're only going to get
more sophisticated and more
invasive.
And so security is
something that you
need to build into your product
and in your development process
from the beginning.
You can't bolt it on later.
So learn about the fundamentals
of securing a product
or system, and then
keep up with the trends.
So that will give
you the confidence
that you need to build long-term
viable products or companies.
JEANA JORGENSEN: Right.
Really great advice.
Thank you for that.
I know it'll be especially
important for new developers
and early-in-career folks.
So thank you.
I mentioned earlier
that I'd give you
a quick rundown of Community
today and how it would unfold.
So let's do that now.
Right after this, there is
a special spotlight session
featuring Jim
Hogan, a health care
strategist in Google
Cloud alongside Vint
Cerf, the co-creator of TCP/IP
and who has often been coined
the father of the internet.
The two will have a
candid conversation
about accessibility
in the workplace.
We think it's going
to be a great session.
And we really, really are
excited to have you join us.
After that, we'll head into
the heart of Community Day.
You can join us in an immersive
gathering experience called
Kumospace, which creates virtual
campus with meeting rooms,
smaller spaces to hang out
for one-on-one conversations,
and then larger auditoriums
for more common topics.
Every single part
of the day will
be powered by Google
Cloud, including Kumospace.
So the day kicks off
with conversations
led by Google Developer
Groups across Europe, Middle
East, and India, and
then the rest of the day,
we'll have a variety
of experiences
and community gatherings
with a few topics
available at each time block.
The first time
block, you can attend
discussions led by Googlers
and community members
like our Google Developer
Experts and expert innovators
dedicated to specific
technologies like Vertex AI,
secure software supply
chain, Flutter, or Workspace.
And then the second block, you
can follow a specific community
pathway and spend time with
specialized groups like Kaggle
data scientists or
Women Techmakers or even
region-specific groups.
And the third and final
track throughout the day
will have dedicated
spaces for learning--
how you can earn a
Cloud certification,
develop new skills in
hands-on lab sessions,
or even apply your skills for
good and philanthropic-related
competition with
other attendees.
We really look
forward to seeing you
and hope you enjoy
the rest of the event.
Join us next for the
DEI spotlight session
with Jim and Vint.
Thank you so much for spending
the last few days with us.
Remember to sign up for
Google Cloud innovators
and become part of our
Google Developer family.
We're excited to get to know
you and spend more time with you
in the future.
Enjoy the rest of Next.